Einstein referenced God a good deal
let's talk for a moment before we
conclude about Einsteins vision of
religion and the greater and the in the
greater whole and how and how his idea
is connected to that okay Einstein was
an extremely clever man as well as being
a deeply smart man
and he used God talk in a variety of
metaphoric ways he himself said that his
God was Spinoza's God the abstract
ordering of the universe he was not a
person of traditional faith in our you
know you know one of the in any of the
revealed religions Judaism as his
tradition he didn't you know the the the
traditional view of God as some
supernatural being acting in acting in
time that was nonsense to him and he
could be very harsh in private
describing this nonsense you know he
went to to Palestine in as as Dan in the
early 20s
mmm-hmm saw traditional Orthodox Jews
praying at the Wailing Wall and was
contemptuous of them I mean his private
writing about it is just you know it's
it's really these people are crazy
they're lost in time this guy at the
same time he really did feel a very
strong sense that the fact that the
universe was ordered and it that order
was accessible to human reason was a
deeply beautiful deeply mysterious fact
of life right and he was perfectly
willing to talk about that in terms that
were congenial to broader discussions
about religion so he used God in lots of
different settings
he's the word God and the concept of
some super ordering power in all kinds
of ways he could again be satirical
I don't believe in it I know he did not
believe in the God of Abraham Isaac and
Jacob or of Jesus or any you know he
that God was not part of Einstein's
lexicon Hey
except to declare that it didn't exist
when a friend of his seriously no friend
to you I mean listen let's be honest a
lot of the lot of his best-known quotes
have to do though with you know God
well yeah but God in that metaphoric
sense or God in that sense to make his
philosophical ideas I think palatable
the wide audiences he was a spiritual
person he believed in things that were
larger than himself but the thing that
he believed in that was larger than
himself was nature and the accessibility
of nature's organization to human
intellect and and you know that was
extremely powerful for him it moved him
he saw himself as you know seeking to be
at one with nature and occasionally
having these spiritual or transcendent
experiences when he felt that he wrote
that in one of his travel diaries
contemplate the ocean this kind of thing
but you know attempting to shoehorn him
into some picture of the scientist who
really secretly believes in a
traditional sense no that's not I say